Trascrizione: Nicoletta Pedrana
Revisore: Silvia Allone
Come potete vedere, questa è una banana
come la conosciamo tutti.
È grande, dolce, buona, senza semi.
Ma non è così che Madre Natura
l'ha concepita.
Ecco com'era una banana
circa 7.000 anni fa.
Certo, non è un bel vedere.
E con tutti quei semi,
non era proprio la nostra banana ideale.
E così l'abbiamo domesticata,
selezionando i frutti migliori,
piantando i loro semi,
facendo crescere le piante,
selezionando di nuovo
i frutti migliori e così via,
fino ad ottenere la banana ideale,
la Cavendish, quella che conosciamo oggi,
che costituisce circa il 50 percento
delle piante di banano nel mondo.
Caratteristiche quali la dolcezza,
la grandezza, la resistenza a patogeni
sono trasmesse da una generazione
all'altra attraverso il DNA,
che è contenuto in ogni cellula
di ogni essere vivente.
Il DNA è una lunga catena di basi azotate,
chiamati adenina, guanina,
citosina e timina,
che costituiscono il codice della vita.
Così come una sequenza di lettere
forma delle parole,
così una sequenza di basi forma dei geni,
che hanno un inizio, una fine,
ed una lunghezza
di alcune migliaia di basi.
Alcune caratteristiche
sono del tipo "tutto o niente":
ad esempio, una banana o una pianta
può essere resistente
ad un patogeno, oppure no.
Caratteristiche di questo tipo
vengono dette "monogeniche",
e sono dunque trasmesse da un solo gene:
chiamiamolo il gene della resistenza.
Se la pianta eredita la versione corretta
del gene della resistenza,
allora sarà resistente;
altrimenti, non lo sarà.
Ho usato il termine "corretta" in quanto,
durante la copia del DNA
da una generazione all'altra,
possono essere introdotti
dei piccoli errori, chiamati mutazioni,
che possono alterare uno o più tratti
che, se vantaggiosi, vengono mantenuti
ed espansi nella popolazione.
E questo è alla base dell'evoluzione,
e permette alla pianta
di adattarsi ad un nuovo ambiente
e di competere con altre specie.
A differenza della resistenza,
non esiste tuttavia
il gene della dolcezza.
Come viene trasmessa questa informazione
da una generazione all'altra?
Questo è un esempio
di tratto "poligenico",
cioè contenuto non in un solo gene
ma in decine, centinaia,
e a volte migliaia di geni.
I tratti di questo tipo
sono di solito graduali:
ad esempio, una banana può essere:
poco dolce, mediamente dolce,
dolce, oppure dolcissima.
Anche l'uomo è cambiato
nel corso degli ultimi 7.000 anni.
Abbiamo dovuto adattarci,
ad esempio in Europa,
a vivere qui con il suo clima più freddo,
e a dipendere da altre specie,
come le vacche d'allevamento,
acquisendo così tolleranza al lattosio
e perdendo probabilmente
la necessità degli occhi scuri
per difenderci dal sole dell'Africa,
acquisendo così altri colori.
Altri tratti che sono in evoluzione
sono, ad esempio,
la perdita dei denti del giudizio
e sembra, anche, la riduzione
della massa cerebrale.
Il motivo di questo ultimo tratto
non è ben chiaro,
ma forse è dovuto al fatto
che passando da nomadi a stanziali
non abbiamo avuto più necessità
di quelle capacità
di orientamento nei boschi,
e di sopravvivenza nella natura selvaggia,
che occupano molte risorse.
Probabilmente, chissà,
con l'uso dei nostri
dispositivi elettronici,
a cui affidiamo la nostra memoria,
si ridurrà ancora.
Chi può dirlo.
L'evoluzione dell'uomo
procede, dunque, senza sosta.
Anche nell'uomo abbiamo tratti monogenici,
come ad esempio l'attaccatura
del lobo all'orecchio;
o la presenza o assenza delle fossette;
o anche la capacità,
che alcuni di noi hanno,
di arrotolare la lingua.
Tratti monogenici sono però,
anche quelli causativi
di malattie genetiche rare -
di solito, purtroppo, pediatriche -
che sono causate da una
singola mutazione in un singolo gene.
Esempi di tratti poligenici, invece,
sono ad esempio l'altezza,
il colore degli occhi,
il colore dei capelli,
ma anche fattori di rischio
per malattie comuni,
quali tumori, infarti,
demenza senile, diabete.
L'evoluzione dell'uomo, dunque,
procede senza sosta;
ma in maniera del tutto casuale,
guidato dall'evoluzione naturale.
Nell'uomo, ad esempio,
ci sono circa 65 nuove mutazioni
che vengono passate
da una generazione all'altra.
Alcune di queste mutazioni
possono alterare uno o più tratti
che, se vantaggiosi,
vengono mantenuti nella popolazione.
Oggi, però, siamo di fronte
ad una rivoluzione,
cioè siamo di fronte alla possibilità
che l'evoluzione dell'uomo
sia guidata dall'uomo,
e non più dal caso;
proprio come l'uomo ha guidato
l'evoluzione della banana.
Oggi possiamo guidare
la nostra evoluzione,
e questo grazie a tre tecnologie
di cui vi parlerò oggi.
La prima delle quali
è quella della lettura del DNA.
Nel 2001,
quando la prima bozza del DNA umano
è stata presentata, è stata svelata,
questo ha richiesto
uno sforzo internazionale
di oltre dieci anni,
ed un costo di circa
tre miliardi di dollari.
Oggi, nel nostro istituto di ricerca
come in tanti altri nel mondo,
abbiamo degli strumenti in grado
di leggere il genoma,
il DNA di una persona,
in meno di un giorno,
a un costo al di sotto dei mille euro.
La tecnologia funziona
attraverso la "colorazione"
delle basi del DNA con colori diversi,
fotografarle,
e poi dall'immagine ricostruire
la sequenza di lettere, di basi,
che forma il nostro DNA.
Quali sono le implicazioni
di questa tecnologia?
La prima, che già oggi è possibile leggere
il DNA di ogni nuovo nato:
possiamo quindi individuare
quelle mutazioni
che, per esempio, causano
malattie genetiche rare.
Alcune delle quali sono "azionabili",
nel senso che esistono terapie
per prevenire, o ritardare,
l'insorgenza della malattia.
È possibile leggere il DNA
anche prima della nascita,
e addirittura prima ancora
del concepimento,
grazie alla tecnica
della fertilizzazione in vitro,
in cui l'ovulo
viene fecondato in provetta.
In alcuni Paesi è già permesso
leggere il DNA dell'embrione
prima dell'impianto
per identificare la presenza
di mutazioni letali
e quindi non compatibili con la vita.
In questo caso, in questi paesi
l'embrione viene scartato
e non viene impiantato.
Prevedo che nei prossimi dieci anni,
con l'aumentare del numero di persone
il cui DNA sarà letto,
saremo in grado di predire
con più accuratezza
anche tratti poligenici.
Quindi, come vi ho detto,
ad esempio fattori di rischio
per malattie comuni.
Sarebbe dunque possibile
associare ad ogni embrione,
prima dell'impianto,
qual è il rischio
che l'individuo che nascerà dall'embrione
svilupperà, ad esempio, tumori.
Ovviamente, selezionare l'embrione
in base alla presenza di queste mutazioni,
e di tratti poligenici desiderati,
non è eticamente accettabile.
Ed è anche praticamente impossibile,
dato la natura completamente casuale
della presenza di mutazioni nell'embrione,
e anche il numero elevato di mutazioni
che conferiscono un tratto poligenico.
Oggi, però, tutto questo sta per cambiare.
Anzi è già cambiato,
grazie ad una scoperta di due scienziate
che hanno individuato
nel batterio dello streptococco,
quello che causa la faringite,
una proteina che vedete
alle mie spalle, chiamata CAS 9,
la quale può essere utilizzata
per legare il DNA
e inserire, cancellare
o modificare una base del DNA
all'interno di una cellula umana.
Già oggi, dunque, in laboratorio
possiamo modificare in una singola base
il DNA di una cellula,
e quindi anche dell'embrione,
prima dell'impianto.
Questa tecnologia,
insieme a quella della lettura del DNA
e della fertilizzazione in vitro,
è davvero rivoluzionaria
per genitori affetti
da malattie genetiche rare.
Ed anche eticamente meno controversa,
in quanto l'embrione
con la mutazione deleteria
invece che essere scartato,
può essere semplicemente corretto,
inserendo la base corretta
al posto della mutazione deleteria.
Dopodiché, l'embrione
può essere impiantato,
e dall'embrione nascerà
un individuo completamente sano.
Nel corso dei prossimi dieci anni,
è possibile prevedere che saremo in grado
non solo di modificare
una singola base nel DNA,
ma decine, centinaia
e addirittura migliaia di basi.
Questo cosa significa?
Significa che potremo
conferire all'embrione
anche tratti poligenici desiderati,
ad esempio basso rischio
di malattie oggi considerate comuni.
Ovviamente, questo apre
un dibattito etico,
e quindi questo è quello
che la tecnologia può offrirci.
La terza ed ultima tecnologia
di cui voglio parlarvi
è quella della biologia sintetica,
che nasce dall'incontro
tra ingegneri come me
e biologi come mia moglie, ad esempio.
E la biologia sintetica ha come scopo,
quello di dotare le cellule
di nuove funzionalità,
utili all'uomo o all'ambiente.
Lo scopo della biologia sintetica
può essere raggiunto
attraverso la costruzione
di veri e propri circuiti biologici,
analoghi ai circuiti elettronici
che oggi troviamo
nei piloti automatici degli aerei,
o anche nel semplice termostato di casa.
Ovviamente,
ingegnerizzare la biologia non è facile,
data la complessità della cellula
ed anche il fatto che questa,
a differenza di un aereo,
si duplica e si adatta all'ambiente.
Per questo, nel mio laboratorio
stiamo lavorando a tecnologie
per la costruzione
di circuiti biologici robusti
all'interno della cellula.
Lo scopo o il futuro prossimo,
quindi non lontano, ma quello prossimo
della biologia sintetica,
è quello di sviluppare
veri e propri farmaci viventi.
Ad esempio batteri probiotici:
quelli che troviamo nello yogurt,
che possiamo ingerire,
ma che sono stati modificati
con circuiti biologici
che li rendono in grado
di riconoscere sostanze tossiche
all'interno dell'organismo -
in particolar modo per quei pazienti
affetti da malattie metaboliche rare -
e quindi curarli.
È possibile anche
inserire circuiti
all'interno di cellule umane,
e questo già oggi sta rivoluzionando
il trattamento dei tumori del sangue.
Cellule immunitarie del paziente
vengono prelevate dal sangue,
e un circuito semplice ma efficace
viene inserito all'interno
della cellula immunitaria,
rendendola in grado
di riconoscere la cellula tumorale
e di eliminarla.
Le cellule così ingegnerizzate
vengono reinserite nel paziente
e possono, in alcuni casi,
curare completamente il tumore.
Ovviamente, come ogni tecnologia,
l'uso che se ne fa può essere
costruttivo o distruttivo.
Ad esempio è possibile immaginare,
in un futuro lontano ma non troppo,
che alcuni regimi totalitari
possano imporre la fertilizzazione
in vitro per legge,
ed obbligare l'inserimento
di tratti poligenici
desiderabili per il regime,
quali una certa altezza
o un certo colore degli occhi;
ma anche, chissà, in futuro,
tratti psicofisici
come bassi livelli di aggressività.
Questo può sembrare uno scenario
da fantascienza distopica, ma non è così.
Nel corso di quest'anno, in Cina,
un ricercatore ha modificato due embrioni
modificando un gene
per conferire agli embrioni
resistenza al virus dell'HIV,
quello che causa l'Aids.
Da questi due embrioni
sono nate due gemelline,
le prime al mondo con DNA riscritto.
Purtroppo, questo è stato fatto
in maniera del tutto nascosta,
sia alla comunità scientifica
che al pubblico;
senza una vera necessità medica
e senza alcuna giustificazione etica.
Il ricercatore in questione
è oggi agli arresti domiciliari, in Cina.
L'unione della tecnologia
di lettura del DNA, di riscrittura del DNA
e della biologia sintetica
apre però scenari davvero incredibili,
e spalanca le porte
all'evoluzione dell'uomo
guidata dall'uomo.
Vogliamo davvero lasciare
l'evoluzione al caso, o vogliamo guidarla?
E fin dove vogliamo spingerci?
Per questo ognuno di noi
ha il dovere di informarsi,
e prendere parte attiva
nella decisione che la società dovrà fare
su dove dirigere gli investimenti
futuri della ricerca
al fine di diminuire le sofferenze umane
nel rispetto della libertà individuale.
Grazie.
(Applausi)